REPUBLICANS IN THE STATEHOUSE
ARE USING THE WORD
"IMPEACHMENT."
BRET?
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
IN TONIGHT'S "WHATEVER HAPPENED
TO" SEGMENT, THE JUDGE, THE
DEFENDANT AND THE SENTENCE FROM
A SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE THAT
SPARKED A MAJOR BACKLASH THAT
FEEDS INTO TODAY'S ME, TOO
MOVEMENT.
CORRESPONDENT CLAUDIA COWAN
REPORTS FROM CALIFORNIA.
>> IT WAS THE SENTENCE CONDEMNED
AROUND THE WORLD AS A SLAP ON
THE WRIST FOR A PRIVILEGED WHITE
SEXUAL OFFENDER AT AN ELITE
UNIVERSITY.
IN 2016, JUDGE AARON PERSKY GAVE
THE 18-YEAR-OLD STANFORD SWIMMER
AND FRESHMAN SIX MONTHS IN JAIL
FOR SEXUALLY ASSAULTING A WOMAN
THAT PASSED OUT BEHIND A
DUMPSTER NEAR A CAMPUS FRAT
PARTY.
VICTIM PERSONIFIED WHAT LATER
BECAME WIDELY KNOWN AS THE ME,
TOO MOVEMENT WHEN SHE READ AN
EMOTIONAL STATEMENT IN COURT
HURLING VENOM AT HER ACCUSER.
"YOU HAVE DRAGGED ME THROUGH
THIS HELL WITH YOU" AND
ENCOURAGING SURVIVORS OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT TO SEEK JUSTICE.
TURNER SERVED THREE MONTHS IN
JAIL AND HAS TO REGISTER AS A
SEX OFFENDER FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE.
NOW, 22, HE'S APPEALING HIS
CONVICTION WHILE LIVING WITH HIS
FAMILY IN OHIO.
WHILE HE CAN'T BE RETRIED,
ACTIVISTS HAVE TARGETED JUDGE
PERSKY THROUGH A JUNE 5TH RECALL
ELECTION.
>> WE THINK THAT THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTY DESERVE A JUDGE WHO
HAS GOOD JUDGMENT, WHO
UNDERSTANDS SEXUAL VIOLENCE, WHO
TAKES THIS SERIOUSLY AND WHO
WILL PROTECT WOMEN, NOT
PERPETRATORS.
>> CRITICS ALSO ALLEGE THE
LENIENT SENTENCE EXPOSED AN OLD
BOY NETWORK BIAS LIKE TURNER,
PERSKY WAS A COLLEGE ATHLETE AT
STANFORD.
IN FACT, HIS RULING WAS ON THE
HIGH END OF A PROBATION REPORT'S
RECOMMENDATION OF FOUR TO SIX
MONTHS.
"CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES EVERY
JUDGE TO CONSIDER REHABILITATION
AND PROBATION FOR FIRST TIME
OFFENDERS.
THE JUDGE WROTE IN A STATEMENT
TO THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS
DEFENDING HIMSELF.
"IT'S NOT ALWAYS POPULAR BUT
IT'S THE LAW AND I TOOK AN OATH
TO FOLLOW IT."
SOME LEGAL OBSERVERS NOW WORRY
ABOUT A RECALL RIPPLE EFFECT.
>> THE RECALL WILL SAY TO
JUDGES, FUTURE JUDGES AND JUDGES
SITTING ON THE BENCH, POPULAR
OPINION IS GOING TO REALLY
INFLUENCE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
WATCHING YOU AND WE'RE GOING TO
-- IF WE DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU'VE
DONE, WE'RE GOING TO COME IN
WAVING THE RECALL PAPERS AT YOU,
TOO.
>> THIS CASE HAS LED TO A NEW
SENTENCING LAW AND A HARD
ALCOHOL BAN HERE AT STANFORD.
JUDGE PERSKY HAS VOLUNTARILY
LEFT HIS POSITION PRESIDING OVER
CRIMINAL CASES AND NOW WORKS IN
AN ON CALL BASIS FREQUENTLY
HEARING CIVIL CASES AT NIGHT.
AND HOPING NOT TO BECOME THE
FIRST CALIFORNIA JUDGE TO BE